Ось так мальовничо виглядали селища в районі Арвайлера до катастрофічної повені.
А так - після.
На місці будинків - суцільна болотяна смуга від брудних потоків води.
І це тільки одне село. А в інших, вище або нижче за течією, ситуація не краща. Це божевілля…
Ще тиждень тому тут був затишний ресторан. А нині - груди сміття, розбитий посуд і поламані меблі.
Власник ресторану Райнгард Ґнат приголомшений лихом.
Але не менше він вражений солідарністю зовсім незнайомих людей та їхньою готовністю допомогти.
У нас було так багато допомоги за перші 24 години, це було неймовірно. Це просто дивовижно.
Не чекаючи допомоги від держави, люди з навколишніх і не тільки міст почали самоорганізовуватися,
брали в руки лопати і хто як міг допомагали розчищати вулиці і будинки.
Коли ми побачили перші кадри того, що сталося, ми зрозуміли, що людям тут знадобиться велика допомога,
бо все це сміття, яке ви бачите на задньому плані, не зникне за один день.
Тому ми вирішили приїхати сюди і зробити все можливе, щоб допомоги.
Повінь практично відрізала цілі містечка від зовнішнього світу, люди чекали рятувальників на дахах своїх будинків.
Загинули понад півтори сотні осіб. Багато людей досі вважаються зниклими безвісти.
Мобільний зв'язок у регіоні повені працює з перебоями або його взагалі немає.
Місцеві жителі допомагають одне одному і рятувальникам, чим можуть.
Ми від самого початку відчували неймовірну солідарність людей.
Ми звели поблизу тимчасове житло для постраждалих, але його більше використовуємо ми самі.
Людей прийняли навколишні готелі та пансіони. Сюди підвозять їжу, тож ми забезпечені всім необхідним.
А це - славнозвісний "Нюрбургринг", автополігон, де відбувалися заїзди "Формули-1".
Нині ж на гоночній трасі замість швидкісних болідів курсують автомобілі з їжею та одягом.
Тут розмістили один з волонтерських центрів, де збирають допомогу для постраждалих від повені.
Нині тут у нас понад 500 добровольців.
Це люди, які просто сиділи вдома і казали: "Я теж хочу брати участь, я хочу допомогти!"
Певно, вже понад 500 людей, набагато більше.
Організатори спершу думали, що це буде регіональною акцією допомоги для найближчих районів,
але вже за лічені години це перетворилося на національний пункт збору пожертв.
Тут чотири зали, заповнені різними речами і тоннами одягу.
Люди з усієї Німеччини привозять сюди гуманітарну допомогу.
Завдяки відносно центральному розташуванню на території "Нюрбургрингу" також розмістилися
оперативні штаби поліції, пожежної служби та організації з надання технічної допомоги.
За словами організаторів імпровізованого центру, готовність німців допомогти просто приголомшує.
Волонтери працюють цілодобово.
Якщо хочете побачити щось позитивне у всій цій катастрофі, то це хвиля готовності  допомогти.
Гадаю, це чудово, я дуже пишаюся нами усіма, нашим регіоном й особливо нашою солідарністю.
Завдяки допомозі волонтерів - моральній і фізичній - місцеві мешканці швидше оговтуються від трагедії.
Ми, сусіди, допомагаємо одне одному. І дуже багато добровольців приїздять і привозять нам воду, каву, їжу.
Сердечно дякую!
Водій екскаватора теж працює добровільно.
Він приїхав з машиною своєї фірми сюди і по 13 годин щодня вивозить звідси руїни й сміття.
Люди тут допомагають одне одному, бо на державну допомогу поки розраховувати не доводиться.
Сусіди працюють разом.
Мій друг тут поряд з пожежниками-добровольцями в Бад-Ноєнар-Арвайлер і допомагає іншим рятувати й прибирати.
Це жахлива ситуація, але згуртованість людей у регіоні неймовірна і чудова - попри катастрофу.
Обсяги матеріальної допомоги жертвам повеней вже такі великі, що німців навіть просять
більше не привозити одяг та інші речі першої необхідності, а допомагати фінансовими пожертвами.
За словами одного з місцевих священиків, біда не залишає людей байдужими,
і за часів великих катастроф, таких, як ця жахлива повінь, вони по-справжньому гуртуються.